[Music]
and good afternoon this is brian ross as
we continue our special coverage of
today's Supreme Court hearings regarding
President Trump his taxes his finances
and the big question is to what extent
is he above the law
joining me to talk about that is former
federal prosecutor Kati Tchaikovsky and
Pulitzer prize-winning journalist David
K Johnson and has tracked a lot about
president Trump's finances and his taxes
and Katie let me start with you what did
you make of today's arguments well it
was just really exciting to see this
format and to listen in to everything
regarding these cases and the cases are
really distinct because you have the
congressional subpoena issue and then
you have the district attorney issue on
the other hand so it was really
fascinating to kind of compare them and
listen to the justices questions as we
went through that process and David Cay
Johnston did you think one side had a
stronger case and the other whether the
Congress had a better argument or Cyrus
Vance the district attorney at Manhattan
well I think the justices and their
questions were surprisingly critical of
some of the concepts being put forth
here by the house the stronger case for
sure is the DA's case and clearly the
best legal argument put forth today was
by Carey done from the New York Attorney
New York district attorney's office the
case by the house was not argued at all
well by mr. letter but I was surprised
that the degree to which the the
justices some of them went to try and
find a way to say well really should we
be burdening the president but this the
New York case is a garden-variety tax
dispute and there's no burden of any
kind on the president these are for
third party records the house
investigation there's not only abundant
evidence but I was very surprised that
mr. letter didn't say Donald Trump
himself has made the argument that
there's a legitimate legislative purpose
by saying he's been abused by the IRS
because he says he's a Christian and
he's even raised that that point
okay teacher cocky let me ask you
because Jay Sekulow president trunks
personal lawyer did argue that even the
district attorney's attempt to get his
tax records and other financial
documents was serving to harass and
undermine the president did you buy that
well I think that it's it's a little bit
of a stretch but I think there has to be
some sort of limitation and I agree that
I think the DA has a much stronger
argument because you have an ongoing
valid criminal investigation and at some
point any sitting president is going to
be subject to criminal prosecution it
might not be now of course but at some
point they can be prosecuted
so that and there's time time is of the
essence in a lot of those cases so I do
agree that there's a priority there as
far as burdening the president and what
might come of that I don't necessarily
concur that just because it's a third
party that has your records that it's
not a burden on you of course it's still
a burden and the courts have long
recognized that you do have an
individual right in a subpoena issued to
a third party that holds your personal
records so that's kind of a little bit
of a cop-out in my opinion he's still
that will be burden to the extent that
there's any sort of oversight any sort
of coordination with the agencies that
hold the records but at what point is it
still necessary and I think there is a
line that has to be drawn I don't think
that the argument that he should never
have to comply with criminal
investigations is really legitimate
because there was no real argument that
the justices didn't seem to accept any
argument that he had absolute immunity
they're looking for a way to sort of
figure out how do you weigh at how do
you balance it isn't that right exactly
and I think that's reasonable because
like I said at some point he can
actually be prosecuted and to the extent
that mr. Dunn made the point that
there's there's been the opportunity for
the quote/unquote floodgates to be open
long long ago and it's never really
happened I don't think that's a huge
concern but of course you still want to
put limits on these questions because
once these these subpoenas are complied
with or a force to be complied with
maybe that will open the floodgates a
little bit more you never know but I
mean for all practical purposes that
hasn't been an issue in the past but I
think the justices were leaning more
towards the idea of Ken
put a hard-and-fast rule which is the
courts role in many of these cases on
when can a president be forced to comply
and when can't they be exactly Carey
done David a Johnson talked about the
parade of Horrible's that he thought
would never happen but there is the
issue of the statute of limitations if
they are prevented from getting the
president's records and continuing their
investigation what do they do about that
if the statute runs out and people who
are no longer be able to be prosecuted
including not just what my president if
he or she were involved with a crime but
people involved with them yeah I I think
Brian this is one of the strongest
arguments that Carey Dunn made first of
all we don't know who the grand jury is
focused on bombing Trump might well be
an ancillary player and the real focus
is on Deutsche Bank which is already
paid over twenty two billion in fines
and over six hundred million just for
laundering money for Russian criminals
is a well-known notorious bank that I've
described is essentially a licensed
criminal organization from the
perspective of the American government
the American citizens and Don is exactly
right there's a tolling of tax statutes
if you're in a tax case but this is a
criminal case and to allow everybody
else who may be involved to run off the
clock to protect the president seems
utterly unreasonable and I don't think
we should lose sight of the fact that
all the way back to 1807
where issues of presidential privileges
and immunities which are absolutely
vital we have to have a recognition that
the president the United States is the
one person who is the sole branch of a
government that the at the same time no
court that I can find anywhere at any
time has ever held that any president
has any privileges or immunities before
he takes office and in this case if it
were to turn out the Donald Trump is a
serial tax cheat a felony tax feet not
infractions as justice courtships said
if he is involved in money laundering if
he is beholden to criminal Russian
elements of which there's lots of
evidence of that we should be very
concerned
and his prior to taking office conduct
should be a massive concern to all of us
and I think the court should keep in
mind as it works this out that the the
importance here is way beyond Donald
Trump what if we get a Democrat in the
White House someday who is a crook that
has a long history of criminal
connections and behavior as Donald Trump
does we meet I don't think we want to be
in a world in which you can run for
president hide potential criminal
conduct and then be shielded because you
are in office it's interesting that as
they pointed out that the requests from
both Cyrus Vance's office in Manhattan
and the two congressional committees
were almost identical ok Jurkowski
could you hear the justices trying to
figure out a framework to try to parse
this issues they could come up with a
kind of compromise any oversight over
the president's office and I don't know
exactly if that's going to lead to an
outcome where they have a rule where
they have to actually articulate a
greater legislative purpose or if it's
going to be that they declined to decide
the question at all because it's
political but I think that that was more
of what I heard from their questioning
at that point you know I was interested
in at one point Justice Ginsburg said I
don't get it why isn't this pretty
simple here what did you make of that
Katie well to the extent that I don't
think it's so simple because I think
there has to be a rule I think that
Justice Ginsburg was trying to make it
that they can obviously ask these
questions they can obviously get access
to all of these documents but really
that's I don't think that's necessarily
the case you have an impeachment process
and if you want to take the president to
task for potential violations you could
go through that but that's not what
these subpoenas here deal with so there
has to be some sort of limit put on all
of these committees suppose
potentially subpoenaing the president
and so I don't agree with that I don't
think it's so simple I think that they
decided to not use certain processes and
try to have broader authority then maybe
the Constitution allows over the office
of the presidency and indicate Johnson
we've talked about this earlier of the
performance of a douglas letter on
behalf of the house was surprisingly
poor yeah i was surprised that he was
not adequately prepared he had to
repeatedly say i can't think of
something at the moment to what were
fairly obvious questions that in prep he
should have gone through but despite the
weaknesses of his presentation and that
should be taken up i want to get across
they don't agree with katy about the
point she just made congress's for the
first article in our constitution
Congress makes the laws the executive is
there to execute the laws and Congress
has to have incredibly broad power and
authority to investigate
now kill more in an 1888 case that I
taught my students till born is a
decision that says you can't go around
mucking into people's personal lives
just to harass them we don't want
another Joe McCarthy type issue here but
there are serious important issues here
money laundering criminal involvement
tax cheating a president who said he'd
show us our tax returns came up with
bogus arguments that you can't release
your returns when you're under audit
which is ridiculous you've already
signed the jurat and you're responsible
for what's there and I think that for
Congress to in any way impose limits
beyond Gilmore would be inappropriate
for the court to do with the interfering
in the most fundamental duty of Congress
which is to investigate and inquire as
Justice Ginsburg pointed out Ginsburg
pointed out so that it can write
legislation which is meaningful and
effective and we shouldn't allow down
the Trump to turn this into what well
Congress you have to do this the way I
say as president or you can't proceed
and that is what he's arguing in both of
these matters the the two House
Committee subpoenas and the grand jury
proceeding I don't like the way you did
this therefore you can't proceed that's
ridiculous you know Katie one of the
things that did not come up in today's
hearings but is a fact is that President
Trump is the first president to break
with the tradition since the least
President Carter not to make public his
tax returns but the question was really
I think for many but what's the added
burden because other presidents have
done just this leading to the question
what has he got to hide what do you make
of that Katie sure and he has decided to
not turn them over that's why we're here
in talking about this but to the extent
that people are saying what have you got
to hide I mean I'm a criminal defense
lawyer I think that that's really not a
valid question because plenty of times
people don't answer questions or provide
documents voluntarily because they don't
legally have to and I don't think that
should be used as something to say that
they're necessarily guilty of anything I
mean that's that's a common
misconception but here he's challenging
the idea that he's obligated to do so
and I think that's a valid legal
question yeah and David Kay Johnson the
Tim O'Brien and we both know an
investigative journalist who was sued by
Donald Trump and actually got a look at
some of trumps tracks with her and said
I saw them you should see them too what
do you think really is in there that is
so much at the stake of the Trunks
resistance to making them public well I
think the New York Times series that was
inspired by my getting Trump's the first
two pages of Trump's 2005 tax return
that series documented without question
the Donald Trump was tax cheap that his
sister who was a sitting federal judge
with tax feet you'll notice she resigned
from the bench as soon as the judicial
inquiry began which ended it because
judges have rules for themselves you and
I don't have that they can stop an
inquiry by resigning the evidence I
think if they get the business records
that are behind the tax returns will
show that Donald is a serial tax cheat
he has a long history he's cheated
workers
there's chapter in my biography of him
the making of Donald Trump about how he
tried to cheat the city of New York out
of 3 million dollars a year and the
farcical lengths that he went to to do
so the only known case ever of a casino
in Atlantic City cheating a player was
at Trump's trump Castle casino Donald
has been cheating people he's had
is find that he's lied he was incredible
his entire life but the business records
are important here the da da already has
his New York state tax return which
under federal law is virtually identical
to his federal return but he can't
proceed without the business records if
he believes that there's criminal tax
fraud by Trump and and he also can't
proceed without the records of the banks
on things like were there Russian
criminals who guaranteed the loans that
don't you bank made the two billion
dollars of loans with no other bank with
loan money to trump and we know this has
gone on at Deutsche Bank in other
circumstances is Donald Trump beholden
to foreign governments in ways that we
don't see because as Trump himself said
in the summer of 2015 the financial
disclosure laws were not written for
some one of his great well finally
though you can't if somebody won't
provide a document they're guilty they
think the Fifth Amendment does not as
you perfectly well know does not make
you it's not an admission of guilt or
anything else we have with these rights
for a reason and we should not in any
way run roughshod over them but at the
end of the day garden-variety
investigations by Congress and the
prosecutor that should be allowed to
proceed all right let me close out here
by asking both of you I know it's
dangerous to sort of read into the
questions from the justices that sort of
predict what's going to happen but Katie
with both the Congressional case and the
case with the Manhattan district
attorney how do you see it playing out
well the case with the DEA I think about
the Jones the Paula Jones case is going
to present a real problem for President
Trump because how do you allow civil
litigation to proceed against a sitting
president and not allow a potentially
more time-sensitive criminal
investigation to at least proceed in
some respect so I think that they could
actually rule against him in that case
as far as congressional subpoenas are
concerned I really feel that and again I
don't know exactly what the questions
were insinuating but I feel like they
might be a little more hesitant to
actually rule against him there because
I think the Congress is really just
office
expedition I think they've tried to
point to general legislative purpose of
course that's the minimal standard but
that really doesn't have any practical
limitation as was shown today during the
argument so I don't know that they're
super inclined to agree that he needs to
comply with those subpoenas but you see
a sort of split decision between the
Congress and the district attorney
that's what I would imagine based on
what I saw today and David Kay Johnson
let me ask you the same question how do
you see it based on what we heard today
in the three hours and 22 minutes of
arguments well let's not forget that
several the justices have expressed that
they don't like starry decisis so they
might well say Paul Jones was wrongly
decided if they want to justify not
allowing the grand jury subpoena to go
forward but I agree with Katie otherwise
unless they're going to say Paula Jones
was wrongly decided and then clearly
they're going to have to let the grand
jury proceeding go I think the house
record which I've read is pretty clear
that there is a real case here and I say
again it was Donald Trump himself who
has made numerous statements indicating
that Congress needs to investigate among
these are you know that he says he's
been discriminated against he claims he
was audited again and again and again to
harass him that's another reason to
investigate and the only known case
since the section 60 103 the tax build
was adopted in the 1920s as an
anti-corruption measure where the IRS
did not turn over documents requested by
Congress involves Donald Trump Donald
Trump has the right to look at your tax
return just like the Joint Committee on
taxation and the chairman of the to tax
writing committees do and so I think
Brian that it's very important that we
keep in mind that Trump is put on a
serious campaign to make sure we don't
see those records we shouldn't draw an
adverse inference from it but we also at
least the court should not draw an
adverse inference I think voters
certainly should but I also think that
we need to have the court look at the
long term here rule and that is should
presidents be
held to a higher standard or a lower
standard than every other citizen when
it comes to questions about whether
they've engaged in things like tax
cheating and money laundering and how we
write rules to address these things like
should we require members candidates for
president to disclose the last six years
of their tax returns all right we'll
expect a decision from the court in a
few months midsummer we're told and that
will be very important we'll play a big
role in the upcoming elections and long
term our presidents above the law David
Kay Johnson and Katie Jurkowski thank
you so much for joining us today thank
you thank you this can you bet and this
concludes our Special Rapporteur on the
law and crime Network fascinating three
hours four hours hearing the livestream
of the justices questioning the lawyers
from both sides fascinating insight into
how the Supreme Court actually works
we'll have to make up our own minds and
wait for the decision I'm Brian Ross
thanks for joining us you're watching
the law on crime Network
[Music]